it's his first public appearance since
he jumped bail and escaped from Japan
the former Nissan and Renault chief
Carlos gon arrived in the Lebanese
capital Beirut over a week ago his case
has brought international attention many
were waiting for the businessmen to
disclose details of how he reached his
country of origin but gone who was
facing trial in Japan on financial
misconduct charges used the news
conference to reiterate his innocence it
is important for me to emphasize that
I'm not above the law and I welcome the
opportunity for the truth to come out
and to have my name vindicated and my
reputation restored I did not escape
justice I fled injustice and persecution
political persecution gone who was
detained a number of times and Japan was
under strict house arrest when he fled
he says he did so because he didn't
believe he would get a fair trial
Japan's judicial system has been
criticized by human rights groups gone
who holds Lebanese Brazilian and French
passports says conditions during his
detention were harsh and he was banned
access to lawyers and his family he's
believed to have arrived in Beirut via
Istanbul on a private jet Turkish media
released video they say show him being
transferred by vehicle to a second jet
Turkish authorities have made arrests an
international fugitive but Carlos Cohen
is not being treated as a criminal by
Lebanon's authorities they say he
entered the country legally the
caretaker justice minister Albert Sirhan
confirmed Lebanon received the Interpol
red notice and would take the necessary
steps but at the same time he stressed
Lebanon and Japan don't have an
extradition treaty gone has been
summoned for questioning by Lebanon's
state prosecutor and Japan's ambassador
to Lebanon asked for more cooperation
but it seems Tokyo officials have few
options even if the extradition treaty
exists the decision to handover someone
is in the hands of the Lebanese
authorities and they still meet to
question Japan has also issued an arrest
warrant Ferguson's Lebanese wife for
giving false testimony but gone is a man
who has
in high places and believed to enjoy
political cover I am proud to be reppin
easy and Lebanon is the only country in
the world that stood by my side the
businessman turned fugitive doesn't hide
his confidence in his words he's ready
to stay a long time in Lebanon XANA
hodor al Jazeera Beirut